[Música]
más de un millón de personas salieron a
las calles de Francia para manifestarse
contra el proyecto de reforma de
pensiones del gobierno de Manuel macron
una ley que alargaría los años de
trabajo necesarios para pensionarse
plenamente y que ha topado con la
oposición transversal de sindicatos y
ciudadanos
y Moscú intercambiaron prisioneros de
guerra mientras avanza la batalla de
bacmut el ministro de defensa ruso
sostiene que se trata de un punto
estratégico para la ofensiva del kremlin
y selenski declaró que no abandonarán la
defensa de la ciudad
en Perú se cumplen tres meses de la
destitución y la detención del
expresidente Pedro Castillo desde
entonces cientos de personas han salido
a las calles en contra de la nueva
mandataria Dina boluarte quien declaró
hoy ante la fiscalía por la mortal
represión de las protestas Tenemos
reporte desde Lima
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mazeu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Francia porque
este martes la sociedad francesa desafió
la reforma del sistema de pensiones
propuesta por el gobierno de Manuel
macron según el Ministerio del interior
francés un millón
280.000 personas salieron a manifestar
contra la iniciativa en más de 300
puntos del país el texto ha levantado
una oposición transversal en la sociedad
francesa sobre todo por uno de los
puntos la prolongación de los años de
trabajo necesarios para retirarse con la
pensión completa el gobierno francés de
momento no consiguió que la legislación
fuera aprobada en la asamblea nacional
Pero espera un resultado favorable en el
senado
un texto que genera un descontento a
gran escala según El Ejecutivo el
objetivo es restablecer el equilibrio
financiero del sistema de pensiones por
lo que propone las siguientes medidas la
edad legal de jubilación pasará
gradualmente de los 62 años actuales a
64 en 2030 es precisamente este punto el
que causa mayor descontento veo a mi
alrededor en muchas profesiones que hay
gente que está completamente agotada
incluso antes de los 60 años entonces
qué pasará si ampliamos el límite de
edad a los 64
los trabajadores nacidos a partir de
1964 tendrán que cotizar 43 años en
lugar de 42 para jubilarse mientras que
la edad máxima de jubilación para las
guerreras incompletas se mantienen 77
años para una pensión completa el
gobierno afirma que la reforma tiene en
cuenta la realización del trabajo en
circunstancias excepcionales pero una de
las críticas es que el texto castiga a
las personas con trabajos penosos porque
les será más difícil trabajar más tiempo
en el transporte hay transporte pero
también hay mudanzas hay muchos trabajos
en los que hay mucha manipulación es un
trabajo duro se imaginan a un trabajador
de mudanzas a sus 64 años bajando un
piano de un cuarto piso no es concebible
la reforma de las pensiones también
prevé el fin de los regímenes especiales
que benefician a los trabajadores de
algunas grandes empresas públicas como
las Industrias eléctricas y del gas O el
banco de Francia el gobierno también
quiere crear un índice sobre el empleo
de las personas mayores un dispositivo
para controlar la situación de los
trabajadores al final de su carrera en
las empresas según El Ejecutivo el
beneficio de la Reforma de las pensiones
se ha estimado en 17,000 millones de
euros en 2030 cambiamos de tema España
va a modificar la ley de libertad sexual
conocida como solo si es si la ley fue
diseñada por el Ministerio de igualdad
una cartera del partido de izquierdas
unidas podemos y a pesar de que el
partido socialista esté en un acuerdo de
gobierno con unidas podemos en el
parlamento los socialistas han pactado
con formaciones de derecha para
conseguir la reforma de la legislación y
elevar las penas de esta ley en los
casos más graves por otro lado en el
marco de la semana del 8 de marzo el
gobierno de Pedro Sánchez ha aprobado un
anteproyecto de ley de paridad entre
hombres y mujeres en los puestos de toma
de decisión tanto en el ámbito público
como en el privado desde Madrid nuestra
corresponsal Marina Colorado nos amplía
pues la ley de paridad que aún tiene que
tramitarse por el órgano legislativo
supone que o pretende que el 40% de los
órganos de decisión como lo dijiste de
la vida privada o pública o de la vida
política o económica esté formado por
mujeres o por hombres en caso de que el
género menos representado algunos
ejemplos de donde se aplicaría esto pues
por ejemplo en las listas electorales
unas listas que tendrían que ser
paritarias con los nombres alternos de
hombres y mujeres en lo que se conoce
como listas cremalleras listas que
afectarían a las elecciones municipales
o generales también a las de los
diputados para el parlamento europeo
pero lo más relevante por la gran brecha
de género que existe es en que se
aplicaría en las grandes empresas las de
más de 250 empleados o que facturen más
de 50 millones de euros anualmente Y es
que la representación de mujeres en los
consejos de administración de estas no
llega ni al 30% entonces con esta ley de
aprobarse lo que hasta ahora son solo
meras recomendaciones o códigos de
buenas prácticas o de buena conducta
sería una obligación así de aprobarse
España estaría cumpliendo con la
directiva europea dos años antes de la
fecha límite puesto que el bloque lo
tiene previsto para que entre en vigor
en julio de 2026 Sin embargo La idea es
que de aprobarse en España esta ley de
paridad entraría en vigor en julio de
2024 en otras noticias en Reino Unido el
gobierno conservador del Primer Ministro
sunak presentó Este martes un nuevo
proyecto de ley contra la migración
irregular el proyecto pretende prohibir
la posibilidad de solicitar asilo a las
personas que lleguen a territorio
británico clandestinamente a través del
Canal de la Mancha una iniciativa que
discursivamente equipara Crimen con
migración y que atenta contra el derecho
internacional al asilo según han
denunciado varias organizaciones
defensoras de Derechos Humanos
en el Reino Unido el Primer Ministro
Richie sunac endurece las leyes
migratorias
nos permitirá detener a los barcos que
están trayendo decenas de miles de
personas a nuestras costas en flagrante
violación tanto de nuestras leyes como
de la voluntad del pueblo británico
no dejarán de venir Hasta que el mundo
sepa que si entras ilegalmente en el
Reino Unido serás detenido y rápidamente
expulsado
expulsados a terceros países como Ruanda
además no podrán pedir refugio un plan
considerado ineficaz y inhumano por los
activistas de los derechos es muy poco
probable que esta nueva legislación
repercuta en el número de personas que
intentan llegar a Reino Unido en busca
de protección Esto se debe a que
simplemente no hay otras rutas hacia
Reino Unido el gobierno debería
centrarse en crear rutas seguras para
que la gente pueda llegar a Reino Unido
y también en crear un sistema de asilo
que funcione en el que la solicitudes se
transmiten a tiempo cada semana decenas
de personas arriesgan su vida para
cruzar el Canal de la Mancha y llegar al
Reino Unido según las organizaciones
decenas de miles de refugiados a los que
se podría considerar asilo corren ahora
el riesgo de ser tratados como
criminales lo que incumpliría con la
convención de la ONU sobre los
refugiados de la que el Reino Unido hace
parte esta convención permite a los
solicitantes de asilo recibir un juicio
justo independientemente de como hayan
llegado a un país tras un brexit que
promete recuperar el control de las
fronteras Richie sunak ha hecho de la
detención de las llegadas de los
migrantes una de sus cinco principales
prioridades vamos con información
relativa a la guerra en Ucrania porque
avanza la batalla de bangmuth en
indonesis según informaron Este martes
las autoridades de kiev antes de la
guerra vivían 70.000 personas en la
ciudad pero tras meses de destrucción
solo quedan 4000 civiles en la urbe y
los combates continúan el presidente
bola de lensky declaró que sus tropas
van a continuar defendiéndose del asedio
ruso por otro lado el ministro de
defensa de Rusia sergeygu aseguró que
ganar esta batalla es crucial para
avanzar en la ofensiva y en otro plano
del conflicto Este martes aquí efi Moscú
intercambiaron prisioneros de guerra
Rusia confirmó la llegada de 130
combatientes mientras que Ucrania
recibió 130 militares de sus filas 87 de
los cuales habían sido capturados en
Mario Paul según informó la presidencia
ucraniana
y entre tanto se cumple un año de la
matanza de la salida de irpping en la
región de kiev recordemos que el inicio
de la guerra las inmediaciones de la
capital fueron escenario de una primera
ocupación rusa que en cuestión de
semanas fue revertida por las fuerzas
ucranianas nuestra enviada especial en
Ucrania Catalina Gómez Ángel viajó hasta
allí y nos envió el siguiente reporte
pasan los días después de ese
aniversario Que recordaba ese primer año
de Invasión a escala máxima ordenada
desde Moscú por el presidente Vladimir
Putin y en la medida que pasan los días
se recuerdan también otros hechos que
hicieron entender la dimensión de esta
guerra a la que estaban sometidos los
ucranianos nos encontramos en la ciudad
de irpín en la cercanías de la capital
que en su momento era el máximo objetivo
de las fuerzas de Moscú y a mis espaldas
está ese que se convirtió en famoso
puente de la ciudad de irpín que fue
destruido en su momento por las fuerzas
ucranianas para evitar el avance de las
tropas de Moscú allí por ese puente en
las partes bajas intentaban cruzar miles
y miles de personas que no solamente
huían de ir pin sino también de la
ciudad de bucha que era asediada y
atacada constantemente por las tropas de
Moscú aquel día el 6 de marzo un grupo
de personas habían ya pasado ese puente
y estaban caminando por el lugar del
frente donde me encuentro y en ese
momento se oyó una gran explosión lo
siguiente que vieron los periodistas y
los policías que ayudaban a estas
personas subir fue estos cuerpos tirados
en la calle luego se conoció que el
nombre de una de ellas era Tatiana una
mujer una madre que venía de la
provincia de donex que había escapado de
la guerra en esa parte del este del país
en el don vas venía con su hija y con su
hijo y también allí venía otro joven de
otra provincia del Don vas de Luján que
también había huido de la guerra en este
momento lo que dijeron quienes
investigaban crímenes de lesa humanidad
de la que la comprobación de que se
estaban cometiendo crímenes contra
civiles algo que se había negado ya
desde Moscú especialmente lo había
negado el presidente Vladimir Putin Así
que esto marcó un antes y un después en
esta guerra luego ya se fueron
conociendo decenas y decenas de
atropellos cometidos por las fuerzas
rusas y en la actualidad hay más de
85.000 investigaciones de casos
similares en el país y un mes después de
los terremotos que devastaron parte de
Siria y de Turquía y en que murieron más
de 52.000 personas la ONU ha estimado
que en 100 mil millones de dólares los
daños materiales causados por la
catástrofe en territorio Turco
recordemos que unas 200 personas han
sido procesadas por su implicación en la
precaria construcción de los edificios
afectados y que la lenta respuesta a la
crisis puede conllevar además la caída
en las urnas del actual presidente de
Turquía recepta Jeep erdogan en las
elecciones de mayo
vamos ahora con información de América
Latina porque en Perú se cumplen tres
meses de la destitución y la detención
del expresidente Pedro Castillo desde
entonces desde el 7 de diciembre cientos
de personas han salido a las calles para
reclamar nuevas elecciones y para
contestar la legitimidad de la nueva
presidenta Dina boluarte y precisamente
boluarte declaró hoy ante la fiscalía en
El marco de la investigación sobre la
mortal represión de las protestas en su
contra Y es que según la defensoría del
pueblo de Perú 60 personas han muerto en
las manifestaciones nuestro corresponsal
Francisco Zacarías nos amplía esta
noticia y también la nueva petición de
prisión preventiva para Castillo
la presidenta Dina boluarte fue
interrogada por la fiscal general de
Perú en la indagación que realiza el
Ministerio Público por la 60 muertes
ocurridas durante las protestas contra
su gobierno la fiscalía suspendió el
interrogatorio hasta que la justicia
peruana resuelva una tutela de derechos
presentada por la procuraduría general
que pide que el organismo participe para
defender al estado en las declaraciones
de los investigados la presidenta
boluarte el Primer Ministro Alberto
tarola y otros funcionarios son
investigados por presuntos delitos de
genocidio homicidio calificado lesiones
graves al respecto del ministro de
Justicia José Tello afirmó que boluarte
está colaborando con la justicia para
que todos los hechos sean esclarecidos y
hoy también se realizó una audiencia de
prisión preventiva contra el
expresidente Pedro Castillo la fiscalía
sustentó el requerimiento de 36 meses de
prisión contra el ex mandatario por los
presuntos delitos de organización
criminal tráficos de influencias y
colusión y afirmó que Castillo podría
ser condenado a 32 años de cárcel si es
que es hallado culpable por su parte
Casio negó ser autor y formar una
organización criminal denunció que se
forma un proceso contra él por supuestas
acusaciones sin fundamento y dijo que se
encuentra preso porque comenzó a cobrar
deudas a empresas que le deben impuestos
al país y señaló que varios de sus
ministros que son investigados tuvieron
la aprobación del parlamento el juez
Juan Carlos chequelle continuará la
audiencia El jueves 9 a las 15 horas
para anunciar su veredicto llegamos así
al final de esta emisión Muchísimas
gracias por su atención sigan con
nosotros y más información
[Música]